[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présenteent le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
claire Planchard bonjour Claire merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous rédctrice en
chef pour les journaux du groupebra les
journaux régionaux de l'Est de la France
el Sliman qui va nous rejoindre dans
quelques secondes président de
l'institut de sondage auxa puisquon on
va découvrir notre baromètre mensuel au
doxa Public Sénat et la presse régionale
et Mathias vous êtes plongé dans le
baromètre vous nous donnerez les
chiffres absolument on va se on va
creuser la popularité de certains
ministres de certains candidats
potentiels et puis est-ce que la course
à la présidentielle a démarré on verra
ça on verra ça dans quelques secondes
d'abord on regarde l'actualité dans nos
régions et l'actualité dans les
collectivités locales c'est cette
annonce du gouvernement d'augmenter la
dotation globale de fonctionnement c'est
la principale dotation au collectivité
pour en parler nous sommes avec Philippe
Laurand le maire udi de saau
vice-président de l'Association des
maire de France bonjour Philippe Laurent
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous dans une
interview à la Gazette des communes la
ministre Dominique fort annonce donc que
la dotation globale de fonctionnement
sera augmenté de 220 millions d'euros
dans le budget 2024 vous saluez cette
annonce écoutez c'est toujours mieux que
rien mais vous savez 220 millions
d'euros c'est entre 1 et 2 % de la
dotation globale hein nous avons vécu
avec une inflation très importante
l'année dernière cette année encore 4 %
l'année prochaine probablement au-delà
de 2 à 3 % et donc par conséquent cette
cette indexation cette augmentation
n'est pas suffisante ça n'est pas
suffisant nous avons nous-mêmes
collectivité territoriale un nombre
important de charges avec des
augmentations fortes sur les prix de
l'énergie euh également nous nous nous
avons l'augmentation qui est d'ailleurs
normale des sal des agents publics or
les collectivités locales emploient
beaucoup de personnes nous
employons 2 million d'AG public ouais
c'est la deuxè année que cette dotation
globale de de fonctionnement est
augmentée est-ce que vous n'y voyez pas
quand même la preuve que le gouvernement
est au côté des élus locaux
oui l'année dernière c'était 300
millions cette année c'est 200 millions
ça fait sur 2 ans 500 millions alors que
la simple indexation de de la DGF
représenterait près de 1 milliard et
demi donc vous voyez que nous sommes
assez loin du compte dimanche soir jtin
un dernier mot Philippe Laurent Emmanuel
Macron a pointé du doigt les maires qui
augmentent la taxe foncière il a dit
c'est de leur responsabilité c'est pas
de la faute du gouvernement qu'est-ce
que vous répondez au chef de l'État
oui alors nous sommes un certain nombre
à avoir trouvé assez blessant les propos
du chef de l'État euh on a le sentiment
lorsqu'on l'écoute qu'il pense que les
enfin l'argent des collectivités
territoriales c'est l'argent de poche
des maires que voilà que d'ailleurs il
dit les maires lorsqu'on parle du budget
de l'État on dit pas euh le budget du
président de la République ou le budget
du Premier ministre il parle des maires
non c'est cet argent c'est l'argent qui
permet de financer les services publics
de proximité dont chacun des français
bénéficie chaque jour et donc euh il y a
pas euh il y a il y a dans cette dans
cette expression et dans cette cette ce
rejet de la responsabilité globale de
quelque chose qui est assez blessant
pour les maires donc je le dis très
clairement et et très franchement et je
pense que nous sommes nombreux à le
penser et c'était très clair merci
Philippe Laur merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin pour réagir à ces
annonces du gouvernement un mot
peut-être clair avant de passer au
baromètre le gouvernement on a un peu
l'impression qu'il souffle le chaud et
le froid avec les élus et tout à fait
tout à fait on sait que le premier
quinquenal d'Emmanuel Macron a été
marqué par beaucoup de défiance de
tension avec les élus au début de son
second mandat il avait tendu la main
notamment pour qu'il participe au au CNR
hein sa nouvelle méthode moins verticale
donc il y avait une espèce de main
tendue une écoute le sentiment pour les
élus locaux que voilà la la la le
nouveau quinquena qui s'ouvrait allit
être différent et là c'est vrai que
cette prise de parole présidentielle au
JT est assez surprenante et on l'a vu
nous dans les conseils municipaux des
villes de la zone du groupe ébra
beaucoup de colère un sentiment voilà
d'injustice et d'incompréhension parce
que localement bah comme vient de le
dire votre invité ce sentiment que bah
en fait l'inflation pèse les dépenses
d'énergie l'indexe enfin la hausse du
point d'indice des des fonctionnaires
tout ça pèse sur les finances et que le
compte n'y est pas et que donc beaucoup
disent que là ça ça ne peut pas ça ne
peut pas durer donc oui c'est c'est
exactement ça il y a une pense une une
incompréhension là sur cette prise de
parole on va continuer à parler
d'Emmanuel Macron bonjour galsman merci
beaucoup de nous avoir rejoint président
de l'institut de sondage odoxa on va
justement parler de notre baromètre
mensuel od doxa pour Public Sénat et la
presse régionale on va le regarder
ensemble on va voir les chiffres d'abord
avec vous Mathias et la première donnée
comme tous les mois c'est la côte de
popularité d'Emmanuel Macron et
d'éizabeth band absolument une code de
popularité euh qui stagne pour le plus
haut représentant de l'exécutif Orian à
la question Emmanuel Macron est-il un
bon Président de la République 32 % des
sondés répondent oui c'est autant que le
mois dernier alors à voir si Emmanuel
Macron qui sort d'une séquence
importante entre l'ouverture de la Coupe
du monde de rugby la visite du roi
Charles II la messe du pape à Marseille
sera en profité pour remonter euh le
mois prochain en revanche elliizabeth
borne elle elle remonte doucement la
pente alors par rapport au mois dernier
la chef du gouvernement gagne 3 points
de popularité ce qui l'apporte à présent
à 31 % de réponse positiv à la question
Elisabeth born est-elle une bonne
première ministre un peu moins exposée
en ce mois de septembre elle a su se
faire oublier après un épisode des
retraites mouvementé un été où tout le
monde y compris ici lui prédisait
prédisait que c'était son dernière été à
matigon
on va décrypter ces chiffres avec vous
évidemment gclg est-ce que la la
stagnation finalement il reste stable
Emmanuel Macron ce mois-ci il faut y
voir le signe d'une rentrée réussie pour
le chef de l'État oui parce que vous
avez choisi le terme stagné et vous avez
raison il est à zéro hein flat par
rapport à l'été mais euh je pense que en
l'occurrence quand on regarde le le
trend la tendance de ces de ces données
on peut dire qu'il se maintient euh il
faut voir que les rentrées politiques
pour Emmanuel Macron pour tous les
gouvernants tous les présidents sont
souvent des moments difficiles les gens
reviennent de l'été ils ont passé leurs
vacances arrivve la rentrée de septembre
les mauvaises nouvelles les difficultés
et en général c'est la dégringolade pour
le chef de l'exécutif pour Emmanuel
Macron pour vous donner deux exemple en
2017 et en 2018 les deux rentrées il
avait perdu plus d'une dizaine de points
par rapport au mois de juin autre
élément intéressant quand même de
contexte vous l'avez très justement dit
ils ont affronté des vents très mauvais
pendant toute la séquence de la réforme
des retraites qui a mis vent debout à
peu près tous les Français et donc on
les a vu dévisser sévèrement alors
certes ils n'ont pas refait leur retard
on en est très loin par rapport à leur
niveau d'avant la la séquence retraite
mais mais en tout cas ils ont stoppé la
baisse et on est plutôt sur un train de
légère remontée on le voit pour
ellizabeth borne alors il y a du boulot
parce que on est quand même une dizaine
de points pour l'un et l'autre en
dessous de leur niveau d'avant la
séquence retraite avant qu'on se mette à
parler de tout ça il y a un an en gros
et bien ils étaient une dizaine de
points plus populaires qu'ils ne le sont
aujourd'hui tous les deux Elisabeth
borne elle remonte plus 3 ça veut dire
que les Français approuvent son le fait
qu'elle reste à matinon ou pas du tout
je je crois je crois je je crois qu'en
en donné d'opinion on a parfois les
mêmes choses qu'en bourse des prises de
bénéfices des des tendances baissières
qui sont interrompu là en l'occurrence
les gens se sont fait une raison ils
voulaient son départ le départ pardon le
départ d'Élisabeth borne ils l'ont
réclamé dans toutes les enquêtes qu'on a
réalisé mais comme il souhaitent le
départ de beaucoup des ministres du
gouvernement parce qu'ils sont
mécontents de ce gouvernement bon ben
ils sont fait une raison elle est là
elle est présente et puis elle est
résiliente donc on est quand même à près
de 7 Français sur 10 qui nous disent que
c'est une mauvaise premierère ministre
et idem pour le président de la
République donc on est dans une
situation ne nous y trompons pas qui est
toujours une situation d'impopularité
clair impopularité mais est-ce que c'est
quand même une rentrée réussie pour
l'exécutif
ben je pense que les chiffres qui
vienent d'être citer le montre les
rentrées politiques sont sont souvent
très très difficiles dans dans les
sondages là on voit qu'il y a eu un
grand activisme Elizabeth B a été
visible moins visible je trouve que
d'autres ministres dont on va peut-être
parler tout à l'heure elle était un
petit peu en retrait l'a entendu appeler
à l'unité essayer de calmer justement un
petit peu les ambitions présidentiell
des uns et des autres en disant il faut
qu'on soit au au travail pour les
Français voilà essayer un peu de de de
calmer les troupes et de les unir mais
oui effectivement on a le sentiment que
le débat sur les retraites est derrière
nous en tout cas c'est c'est le
sentiment qu'on a dans l'actualité aussi
la l'entrée en vigueur de la réforme n'a
pas sucité de remou on a des
manifestations là qui s'annoncent mais
on ne s'attend pas voilà un automne
social pour le moment très très très
virulent un mot peut-être dans le détail
de ce son sondage parce que vous avez
fait le détail par appartenance en tout
cas par sympathisant en fonction des des
groupes politiques et on voit que chez
les sympathisants d'Europe Écologie les
vers c'est l'explosion de la popularité
aussi bien d'Emmanuel Macron que
d'Élisabeth Bor plus 23 points et plus
26 points depuis le mois de juin ouais
alors vous avez reçu y a pas longtemps
enfin quelques instants marine Tondelier
il y a une grande différence chez les
écologistes
entre les sympathisants et les militants
les sympathisants écologiques
ce sont représent des des centaines de
milliers ou des millions de Français qui
disent dans une enquête bah le parti
dont je me sens le plus proche ou disons
le moins éloigné c'est Europe Écologie
Les ver et très souvent parce qu'ils
sont à peu près
apolitique les personnes interrogés et
donc ils ont le sentiment que l'écologie
c'est gentil c'est sympathique ils
peuvent voter pour des écologistes à
certaines élections mais ils ne sont pas
du tout militant et puis vous avez une
autre catégorie de la population qui
sont les militants des différents partis
politiques et les militants écologistes
eux sont sur des des lignes politiques
beaucoup plus fermes beaucoup plus dur
beaucoup plus marqué et donc je crois
que chez les sympathisants Europe
Écologie Les Verts c'est simplement des
gens qui sont plus éloignés de la
politique pour qui toute cette affaire
des retraite qui les a beaucoup agacé et
Ben est derrière nous et donc c'est
principalement pour cette raison qu'elle
remonte et certainement pas en raison de
prise de position en faveur de
l'écologie ou de l'environnement on va
passer au cœur de ce baromètre la
question de ce mois-ci la course à la
succession d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce
qu'elle est engagée selon les Français
Mathias dans l'esprit des Français la
les luttes intestines au sein du camp
présidentiel et bien elles ont bien
démarré Orian puisque 83 % de nos sondés
répondent oui à la question la
succession Emmanuel Macron a-t-elle
commencé alors une fois cela dit on n
absolument rien dit il faut savoir qui
est à la lutte et qui pourrait incarner
un potentiel successeur au chef de
l'État alors sans surprise Édouard
Philippe et pour 50 % des personnes
interrogées un bon candidat pour représ
présenter la majorité présidentielle en
2027 il estalonné de loin mais c'est à
noté quand même par Gabriel Atal qui
enregistre 29 % d'opinion favorable 70 %
des favorables attention 28 % pour le
duo d'armanin le maire Olivier verrand
Jean Castex et elliisabeth born ferme la
marche avec respectivement 19 18 et 17 %
des sondés qui voitent en eux des bons
candidats pour la prochaine élection
présidentielle dans 4 ans c'est toujours
bon de le rappeler d'abord le chiffre 83
% des Français pensent que la succession
est est lancée c'est un chifre
surprenant ou pas g alors oui et non non
d'abord c'est pas surprenant parce qu'on
a tous vu cette rentrée politique avec
les courses Gérald daranin qui prend
position ellisabeth borne qui court pour
venir le rattraper ENF ce que vous avez
très bien commenté à cette antenne est
présenté les gens l'ont vu donc d'abord
ça n'est pas étonnant que les Français
s'en rendent compte mais oui quand même
parce que 83 % c'est énorme ça veut dire
qu'il y a aucun doute et surtout oui
parce que que ça signifie quelque chose
de la crédibilité du mandat à venir
d'Emmanuel
Macron la force d'un président de la
République c'est que c'est nous sommes
dans un régime un peu fou ultra
présidentiel à un point qui n'existe
nulle part dans le monde dans une
démocratie et donc c'est un peu le roi
thaturge le président de la République
c'est celui qui peut tout faire et donc
quand le président de la République bah
on sait déjà qu'il ne sera plus là qu'il
ne se représentera plus il perd beaucoup
de sa superbe dans l'opinion donc ce 80
affaibli c'est un président affaibli bah
c'est un président qui est affaibli dans
l'opinion il est affaibli pour des
questions d'impopularité on l'a évoqué
avec les retraite puis il est affaibli
parce que on sait qu'il va passer la
main et que d'une certaine manière pour
pouvoir être légitime à prendre le
relais il faudra que son successeur
putatif marque une petite distance avec
lu une petite rupture donc ça promet des
des des mois assez folkloriqu en terme
de TER d'épisode po on va venir sur les
successeurs mais clair sur ce chiffre he
83 % est-ce que il y a le risque d'un
quinquena pour rien pour Emmanuel Macron
il sera inaudible euh je pense que les
législatives ont quand même jouer un un
point important fait qu'il ait perdu
cette majorité relative à sa capacité
d'action parce que tout le monde sait
que Emmanuel Macron allait être le
premier président de la 5e République
qui pourrait pas faire plus de mandats
voilà depuis 2008 donc c'est le premier
à 45 ans il mais il y avait une espèce
de règle un peu tacite qui était de dire
on attend les européennes pour commencer
à en parler c'était un peu la cisure du
mandat on voilà donc au sein de de la
majorité même si voilà Edward Philip n'a
pas caché ses ambitions notamment depuis
la création d'horizon on savait mais à
l'intérieur du de la majorité et c'est
vrai quein geréral de darmana a un peu
fait battre ce ce ce consensus avec
cette rentrée politique fracassante on
sait que pour lui de pas avoir eu
matinon a été sans doute un échec il a
voulu voilà créer un peu l'événement et
et il s'est exprimé publiquement en
parlant de son inquiétude pour 2027 et
là je pense que
médiatiquement ce que tout le monde
savait a pris une évidence flagrante et
puis ben on on a vu même ellisabeth
borne et puis bah gabrielal on en
parlera qui a aussi joué à dire c'est il
est pas le moment voilà de se préoccuper
de 2027 mais bon voilà c'est devenu sur
la place publique un enjeu avec des
petits coups de com de part et d'autres
des prises de parole donc là je pense
que ça a vraiment marqué une rupture oui
dans la dans cette perception qui tout
le monde savait qu'Emmanuel Macron ne
pourrait pas mais comme en plus il a
empêché voilà il y a y a il y a un vrai
enjeu je pense ouais sur les successeurs
puisque vous avez testé les successeurs
alors on va d'abord commencer par les
successeurs dans la macronie évidemment
ga Siman c'est Édouard Philippe qui
arrive en tête est-ce que c'est parce
qu'il a trouvé à la fois le juste milieu
entre la continuité est-ce que vous nous
disiez tout à l'heure il faut commencer
à se détacher du chef de l'État oui sans
doute et puis ça fait un moment d'abord
notre baromètre politique chaque mois
vous c'est un peu répétitif vous voyez
code des personnalités oh Édouard
Philippe numéro 1 ah bah
tiens et ça fait des années maintenant
ça fait depuis qu'il a quitté Matignon
en gros dans dans les dans le mois qui a
suivi ou les deux mois qui qui ont suivi
il était numéro 1 en terme de code
d'adhésion donc le fait que les Français
le perçoivent le pensent comme le
meilleur candidat putatif de la macronie
de la succession Emmanuel Macron n'est
pas étonnant le le niveau de de
d'opinion favorable sur sa candidature
est très élevé quand même 50 % ce qui
est intéressant c'est de mettre ça en
relation avec notre code d'adhésion et
de voir que Édouard Philippe a trois
avantagees il est l'homme politique
français qui suscite le plus d'adhésion
c'est plus que de la popularité he
c'estàd qu'on est en sympathie avec lui
ou qu'on le soutient donc c'est c'est
quelque chose d'assez d'assez solide il
a le plus d'adhésion il a quasiment à
chaque fois le moin de rejet c'estd que
on peut avoir des personnalités
clivantes comme on dit qui suscitent de
l'adhésion mais beaucoup de rejet ça a
été le cas de la famille Le Pen pendant
très longtemps c'est encore un petit peu
le cas euh et troisièmement on pense que
ce serait un candidat très légitime pour
pour la successession d'Emmanuel Macron
mais ce qui est le plus intéressant
c'est pas Édouard Philippe pour moi ce
mois-ci le plus intéressant c'est
Gabriel Atal parce que Gabriel Atal il
n'existait pas beaucoup dans l'opinion
avant l'été et d'un coup d'un seul lui
c'est vraiment celui qui a le plus
réussi sa rentrer il se retrouve
propulsé sur le devant de la scène dans
l'opinion on va en dire un mot sans
doute mais en code d'adhésion il flambe
c'est assez inédit une telle progression
et il se retrouve directement alors il
est encore loin d'Édouard Philippe en
crédibilité pour 2027 mais il se
retrouve
directement à la deuxè place devant des
candidats qui son candidat quasiment
depuis la naissance Gérald daranin à
peine les gens l'ont connu il était déjà
candidat un petit peu comme Nicolas
aussi alors il est devant oui un peu
comme Bruno Lemer mais dans le casadre
d'armanin c'est encore plus
spectaculaire je pense parce que Bruno
Lemer les gens le connaissaient d'avant
il avait occupé plusieurs ministères il
s'était présenté face à Nicolas Sarkozi
pour pour pour diriger la droite là on a
vu une personnalité émergée on a
découvert son nom son existence et en
même temps qu'il était candidat à tout
et du coup ça ça a suscité dans
l'opinion des éléments antagonistes sur
Gérald armanin et comment vous expliquez
cette percée de Gabriel àal ah bah pour
ce que l'on a vuil changé de ministère
déjà ça faisait un moment que les gens
l'entendaient le voyaient il a réussi la
performance d'avoir occupé des fonctions
de type porte-parola où normalement on
se fait détester par tout le monde parce
qu' on est obligé d'avaler les
couleœuvres d'enfoncer des portes
ouvertes de répéter des éléments de
langage absurde c'est ce que font tous
les porte-paroles de dans tous les
partis poli
et là il a réussi à le faire avec un
certain talent et puis il a émergé dans
l'opinion en arrivant à se faire
connaître sans se faire détester ce qui
est rare pour des ministres du
gouvernement et pour finir il a eu cette
rentrée politique très réussie en
succédant à un ministre de l'éducation
que les gens avaient peu vu qui avait
peu imprimé pas toujours avec des
éléments très positifs à l'esprit
s'agissant de de PAP indal et et en
prenant position sur des sujets où
l'opinion était d'accord avec lui que ce
soit sur la BAA ou que ce soit sur sur
le fait de revenir à des fondamentaux
plus logiques sur le baccalauréat et
donc il a il a coché toutes les cases de
la réussite et c'est ce qui explique
qu'il a bondi de 11 points sur notre
code d'adhésion des personnalités
politiques c'est le record depuis très
longtemps et c'est effectivement le fait
marquant de ce baromètre claire Gabriel
Attal il s'impose comme un successeur
crédible ah on est en 2023 mais oui oui
le fait est que il a été propulsé
effectivement sur un ministère très
difficile hein son entourage je crois
beaucoup en tout cas le le lui disait
que c'était c'était c'était trop risqué
parce que le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale c'est très risqué en plus
c'est un domaine réservé du Président on
a vu que voilà dans cette interview au
point Emmanuel Macron l'avait un peu
précédé et malgré ça une expression que
je trouve assez chouette c'est de dire
queil arrive à exister sans cacher le
soleil c'est-àdire qu' il arrive à être
dans un périmètre qui est vraiment
présidentiel et à prendre la parole à
être présent même par rapport aux
enseignants qui sont pas d'accord avec
lui surtout c'est un professionnel de la
politique les syndicats sont assez
contents d'avoir quelqu'un qui connaît
les codes qui agit a qui peuvent avoir
voilà même si sur le PACT voilà
enseignant plein de sujets clivant il a
il y a des
désaccords ils ont un interlocuteur
voilà qui qui maîtrise les codes et lui
quelque part il a une stratégie très
différente de celle de daramanin qui est
de se dire bah il y a un espace central
créé par Macron dans le dans le dans le
dans le théâtre politique et je vais y
aller je vais m'adresser aux classes
moyennees enfin il a un positionnement
très différent qui voilà selon le le
sondage est est bien perçu il va y avoir
un match à tal d'armanant non je enfin
je je d'abord je je fais jamais de
pronostic parce que on est habitué en
sondage à voir des favoris un an plus
tard disparaître donc je fais pas de
pronos pour l'instant ce qui est
formidable c'est qu'il y a pas de match
vous avez vous regardez tous nos
indicateurs vous m'avez cité Bruno Lemer
bah voilà une personnalité politique qui
imprime qui existe auprès des Français
qui sont les poids lourds en politique
bah c'est pas très compliqué vous avez
Édouard Philippe très haut et puis
aujourd'hui vous avez àal vous avez le
maire mais Gérald armanin n'est pas
vraiment un poids lourd les gens sont
fait l'idée qu'il serait candidat mais
quand vous regardez sa code d'adhésion
et code de rejet il suscite beaucoup
beaucoup plus de rejet que d'adhésion et
c'est pas nouveau en fait c'est un poids
lourd dans le microcosme politique et
d'un poids lourd médiatique mais en
terme de popularité en terme d'opinion
en terme de code d'adhésion sur toutes
les dimensions possibles en terme
d'intention de vote quand il est testé
dans des intentions de vote à la
présidentielle par certains confrères il
est très loin des Bruno Le Maire ou
aujourd'hui d'un d'un Gabriel àal donc
s'il y a un match aujourd'hui qui se lit
je ne fais pas de pronostic si c'était
demain il se jouerait probablement entre
un favori Édouard Philippe et puis des
des outsiders comme Bruno Le Maire qui
qui fonctionnent bien dans l'opinion qui
réussit comme àal à susciter adhésion et
pas trop de rejet il joueraient plutôt
sur ces personnalités là on voyait
Olivier verérrant alors il est décroché
en crédibilité pour se présenter mais en
terme de code d'adhésion il est depuis
longtemps dans les tops 3 qu de la
macronie c'est plutôt là-dessus que le
match se jouerait aujourd'hui mais
encore une fois ce qui se joue
aujourd'hui n'a rien à voir avec ce qui
se passera dans 3 ou 4 anouû et à
l'heure actuelle et un mot peut-être sur
Elisabeth borne qui est beaucoup moins
populaire que ces ministres on le voit
dans tous vos indicateurs ah bah
Elisabeth borne est très loin elle
suscite elle aussi en terme de
crédibilité pour se présenter des
niveaux très faibles et en code
d'adhésion elle est moins populaire mais
surtout elle suscite beaucoup plus de
rejets vous avez les deux ministres qui
suscitent le plus de rejet dans ce
gouvernement s'appelle Gérald daran he
et Elizabeth borne claire un petit mot
peut-être sur Elisabeth borne non non ce
que je je disais tout à l'heure c'est
vrai que là on a l'impression qu'elle
essaie de tenir plus que de d'émerger
comme en tout cas dans la course à la
présidentielle elle elle niit toute
toute toute véléité elle elle est
vraiment dans un rôle on lui avait
prédit voilà de pas avoir une nouvelle
rentrée enfin que que c'était un
remanimement quelque part qui était pour
pour ne pas perdre une cartouche avec le
prochain 493 on vraiment c'était un
fusible en fait donc voilà donc là elle
est résiliente elle m voilà elle mais
c'est sûr que elle a du mal dans ce
contexte à émerger véritablement comme
une une présidentiable c'est pas le
c'est tout à fait exact ce que vous
dites d'ailleurs quand
même les deux précédents cas où on a vu
des premiers ministres un petit peu dans
cette posture il y a eu un peu Édouard
Philippe une certaine manière et puis il
y avait François Fillon sous Nicolas
Sarkozi résultat cette posture du
Premier ministre écrasé par son
président maltraité et puis qui continue
de faire bonne figure qui ne se plaint
pas qui taille sa route et ben ça vous
permet quand même à moyen terme de
marquer des points dans
l'opinion